good morning millennial Oh Millennials
we are back it's been so many years it's
been so long since i sat here with you
know right like I was gone Friday and
Thursday Thursday so it's been Wednesday
to Wednesday Wow a whole week but we
obviously filled the void with premium
content premium guests we had we had
Heather McMann we had Olivia ashtray
how was Heather McMann Heather McMahon
was amazing she she just cracks me up
like even just being herself before she
even is being funny she makes it a
breeze then we had Olivia who funny
enough was our hardest guest to mail
down like trying to get her on the show
has proven to be rather difficult I mean
the life of a traveling marketer is it
never stops its trials and tribulations
and now we're trying to plan her
bachelorette party have you been talking
to her yeah she's having a hard time is
she I thought it's like I'm pushing my
personal agenda cuz I really want to go
to Austin but she's been so many times
and she doesn't want to go no I think
you're right like I don't think it's the
vibe I think it is and if we're gonna go
to Austin we should just move it to a
different weekend and go to Nashville
and it will be I said that too cuz it's
the same thing but I've never been to
Austin so I won't actually going to
Austin in like two weeks so for what for
a wedding I really want to go to Austin
but it looks like it's not gonna happen
you should just do a show there and then
yeah yeah at UT go horns go horns they
won this weekend at the Cotton Bowl I
only know that because of Rachel Lindsay
she's keeping me informed
I did a swipe up for my boots so much
money no I didn't make any but Rachel
Lindsay bought them okay wait and you
know who makes my boots
I'll give you DSL you know that's a
store that sells them okay wait don't
look at the bottom I will give you five
guesses and I bet you I could give you a
million guesses and you wouldn't guess
it okay candies close mango no I'll give
you another clue it's a the celebrity
has a brand Jessica Simpson nope JLo
nope what more Kristin Cavallari nope
Fergie Wow these are the Fergalicious
boots I didn't even know she had a sheet
that's why I [ __ ] so hard but TSW
these days who'd have known and these
like the fake Chloe boots that literally
cost seven million dollars and like
please just try to get them sweaty
thanks Chloe I'm good
DSW $59 like I am so here for 59s w like
I'm the knight no you after all
they do a lot of in circuit age is why
I'm out here thirsting for some business
right I wonder if they do you podcast
marketing like yeah where to find those
brand deals aren't coming through like
they used to email in bio mmm-hmm um I
just yeah I'm so happy to be here I know
it's been so it's been so difficult you
know yeah Cobo thing is hard like
hosting with a new host yeah and I like
so used to like have FOMO that I never
got to do it and now I don't have FOMO
anymore how was the snitch on the toast
snitching the chest was easy I feel like
we had lots to cover and we did just
that I feel like it was a very specific
episode like we really talked in circles
a lot like we spoke for like 30 minutes
about Riverdale a conversation we had
had like on the play and the day before
so we were acting like we did it oh my
god you were acting yeah and never
happen I miss Alabama like we were just
talking like like like sisters Yeah
right so I couldn't tell if people would
like that or not I think that's what
make that's the magic of the show I've
got magic in me I've got the magic did
you see Ben Watts Instagram I couldn't
singing 5 seconds of summer I did so
because someone was kind of to record
the whole thing and put it in the
toaster you think it's hard for him I
was thinking like June it's hard for him
till I go from like the toast of
Broadway to just like an actor do you
know I mean no because I think if he
wanted to continue to be the toast of
Broadway he could be you know I think he
was over it and at the time and now it's
just like now what I feel like he
definitely misses it you know the bar is
definitely high yeah like what can you
do next I'm sure he'll do something cool
there's always cool projects being
worked on like a star is born yeah he
lost so much weight for the role I
wonder if he's gonna getting some back
nice anyhow bless she Jewish face he
needs any recommendations yeah you know
a couple Esther ons I can recommend uh
anyways my weekend thanks for asking was
weird he spoke about it so like what's
fun-filled I was really sick like the
whole time I was in down at a friend I
brought a friend Big Tex
I took my engagement photos at the State
Fair this weekend with Anthony baskets
did you see like a trooper I did not see
LeeAnn but I'm glad I did him because I
I've never worked so hard in my life
of course how many alpha changes for
outfit changes total like where did you
change in bathrooms and there were nice
bathrooms and like it was actually like
I just went handicapped so I had a
suitcase and I was freaking out there
were so many moving pieces it was like
getting Anthony there Zack our outfits
pictures people etc I was like how are
we gonna get suitcases through security
like they're gonna be like this is so
weird night like I was I had spoken to
the PR team before and they said it was
fine I mean when I got there like people
literally we're living at the fair like
they had wagons and like super camp
there I don't know but they had wagons
like they didn't even bat an eyelash at
my suitcase like like a wagon wheel so
much more um but it was just it was
really great I really think we got some
really premium probably due to the
previews of the photos that I saw were
we're highly premium of course and it
was just so crazy we were supposed to
take the pictures on Tuesday but the
weather of course I pick one day a
record of the fair yeah it doesn't rain
in Texas I picked the one day it's
monsoon so then we're like we're gonna
have to make a go within on Monday
before the Sun Goes Down it starts as
I'm getting ready it's pouring rain we
get in the car it's pouring rain we're
literally driving into the storm we pull
up into the parking lot and it stops
raining Hashem for two hours completely
clear we got all of our pictures done
then after the pictures we like we're
just getting food at the fair
would you eat oh I didn't get to eat
that much cuz then it started monsoon
again but the most delicious thing I had
was a piece of pizza that was like so
doughy and it was like just cheesy bread
it was so good I had some saltwater
taffy which is like don't waste her
tolerated Zack had a corn dog I heard
good things
I had a liitle bit of cotton candy can't
[ __ ] that up
I've never had a corn dog but I feel
like I would really I feel like I think
it would it would be my I didn't think
you and Mario would love because I love
a hot dog yeah and it just makes it
easier because you get to eat it on a
stick I had a delicious fountain soda in
this big text oh that's so jealous
she's an ear cup and it's just so funny
cuz when I went to the fair was wearing
like a white dress hair done everything
I looks like one way I mean the time I
left us today the fair I took my change
into one of sacks t-shirts that said
Texas on it and it was like really big
and long and I bought a fanny pack so I
could hold my job and I was drenched by
the rain holding my big cup and my pizza
and I looked like a fair goer yeah I
looked like two different you a fellow
cake I didn't I didn't have like that
much time to get food in and then when
we did it started raining so I was like
let's just get the hell out of here what
was that amusement park me to go to I
cam biga I can't oh I'm fun
there was the Excelsior is there yeah
what was it called
Funland can you Google Excelsior roller
coaster men made because they had the
like
the most delicious food but when I think
of their food funnel cake the same Joey
pizza but with jet bread maybe that was
the funnel cake yeah
where it's like looks like a big waffle
yeah and then you put powdered sugar on
it not the Excelsior Excalibur Excalibur
yes here what is that [ __ ] they had
tried Oreos fried fried Oreos fried
Snickers
Funtown Splashtown I told you was
something called fun fried PB&J
they had fried beer they had fried
everything how do you drink fried beer I
didn't get around to it oh my god that
sounds so epic like I wouldn't need to
go and just like be that it was really
crazy it was and it was like the biggest
State Fair in the world
they sold hot tubs there's a car show
like it was massive we walk 9 miles we
reach Anthony J fair probably upstate we
should go we should go and I just love
like carnival food I'm big into state
fairs and I'm glad that there's still a
thing like there's new to me it's just
like such pure hearted fun and like now
that you know there's no more circus
shows and like people aren't good
limited-use like no it's good it's good
clean fun fun for the whole family I
love good clean fun GCL so those
pictures will be coming out soon stay
tuned for the premium content I really
hope that I say that just don't look fat
and sweaty after no that's the magic of
Anthony Vasquez after all the links that
I went to write he knows I was sweating
like an absolute wildebeest in my
engagement photos it was the [ __ ]
hottest day of the year in the concrete
of New York City the concrete jungle and
I looked amazing because Anthony Vasquez
he knows what to do he knows that we
totally fun
we took some wild so does that like
probably won't see the light of day like
we took some photos on a John Deere we
took I showed you under the sign that
says cattle which is like just I don't
know so I don't know that it's good
brand messaging right we did a
caricature there's like pictures of us
while the caricature is being drawn of
us really cute really fair vibes I
really just wanted to pay tribute to
Zach's heritage being a Texan text is
strong yeah and I think we achieved that
so thank you Anthony for accompany me on
this journey did you do anything else
while you were in Dallas I saw stars
born okay meet me and Margaret seeing it
tonight Chuck you mate I know coming
well the way the weirdest thing me and
Mike I went to buy tickets tell me if
you ever heard of this for at 9:40 show
because we want to watch over del and
then go and on the website it said only
discount tickets available so we're like
what I think that meant
like if you have like AARP or like
senior discounts like veterans yeah like
when you just want the regular tickets
so the theaters completely empty and the
only seats you can get are with your
discount so we call and we're like hello
how can we get tickets they're like oh
after body astray after nine o'clock all
tickets are discounted
wow that's great look I knew that after
before noon Adam movie theater you can
get like a $5 ticket cuz like not much
goes on there but after nine o'clock
there all these different tickets I saw
stars born with Sachs Graham she had the
senior discount I don't know I'm going
into the movie I had no reason anyway
senator it's gonna be exactly how you
feel oh speaking of huh do you see
Mariah Carey perform I mean she
literally oh she made me sick no she's
so skinny when you call me I was on the
toilet she's so squishy she drove me to
illness and like she that her belly
wasn't even moving at I know she wasn't
singing her dress was so tight that if
she was actually just like expressing
her vocal chords her belly would have
moved a little bit she was a statue she
didn't move I mean what a waste of time
but like they had you know much talent
to choose from last night but like he
could have done without that and it's
like why can't she just stop and enjoy
the fruits of her labor like who's
making her do this right like she does
not be coming out with new music new she
really does it her and Brittany I grant
it anyone in Vegas and no offense JLo
oh not none taken I completely agree
like her list of hits is impressive and
dynamic and is enough for years and
years in Vegas
I don't need to hear dinero right I
don't need her he's all good like that I
don't need her to song with four other
people like leave it to bebe Rexha like
you're gold you're like yeah you're in a
legal mirror but JLo's literally taking
away opportunities from like Becky G no
like no one else can get these
opportunities because JLo is taking all
of them when it's like become you're an
icon already like sit down right you are
like performing at like fundraisers
where they just pay like millions of
dollars to come and perform like that's
the goal like yes the way that you're in
a new movie coming out that looks very
bad but like she'll she told me about
JLo is that she's consistent and every
movie she makes is absolutely horrible
absolutely well yeah I mean like post
iconic JLo it's after Taylor became an
icon and singing she didn't want to stop
doing everything I don't she continues
to just like make terrible movies and
make terrible music and it's like be
here an icon sit down no she really she
could sit down and also she really
wasn't singing I say it didn't even
sound like her voice and I know that
song was written by SIA and I sounded
like SIA like who are you trying to fool
JLo never sings she's consistent but you
want to know what she's an incredible
dancer look she wasn't dancing either
sorry she stood in one place and sang
and like she was trying to sell it so
hard I was like mad at her I was like I
know you're not singing and the harder
you try to make me think that you're
singing like what a phony like she was
acting which I guess is what she's
always wanted to do totally her true
passion but I watched like a decent
amount of the American Music Awards do
you feel me like do you feel like nobody
was there well none of like the bigwigs
were there except for Taylor Taylor now
nobody else did nobody felt like they
had to like they all picked up the baton
for years for her while she like sat out
for three years so like now they're
staying home right and it's like now
that I think about it like people were
there JLo Mariah like cardi but like
ariana grande wasn't there Nicki Minaj
wasn't there who else wasn't there
Katy Perry wasn't there all right um I
have a seen the same thing about ariana
grande
Kanye wasn't there like yeah maybe it
just feels like it wasn't like a real
award show cuz Ariana wasn't there she
literally goes to everything and she has
a new music out so she should have been
there pushy you know personal things
right so that's why it was straight
Nicki Minaj I think it's a bit all hey
Taylor which is just so hilarious we
have a story about the AMA so we'll be
able to like dive into it the big
winners and the perform
and the outfit heard around the world
and will give you all of our thoughts
once we get there but without further
ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast we
obviously have some breaking news today
because the world never stops and
neither does the toast no and neither
does the courts neither does I see II
know they never stand for UM generation
Center center emergency what are you
doing over there on your computer yelled
at me for scolding them because I said
that someone's gonna spoil it you get
homework yeah we pay attention Yeah
right okay I see you Sam for as I'm
catching up on Desperate Housewives
which is just it has really just
improved my time on earth and it's when
Gabrielle Solis and Carlos Solis who by
the way out of all the men on the show I
believe Carlos is my favorite and I
think he's like such a good husband he's
daddy as he'll be de like and like that
I love men who like want kids so badly
and like when Gaby's being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like I'm kind of hating Gaby
she's just like she is Carrie Bradshaw
vibes like making the worst decisions
and like you're supposed to like her but
I like she's still beautiful that like I
still like her but every time she does
something she makes she's so stupid and
it's like you think I'm literally like a
woman what if she supposed me in her
forties thirties there he's like even
that dumb woman in their 30s doesn't
make as many bad decisions as Gabrielle
Solis like she's so stupid and like
every time she does something I'm like
that's just a bad idea but I just still
love her like I don't end up hating her
like I hate Teri Hatcher but Carlos is
just everything he's so hot he like
loves her so much he's the only person
that puts her in her place and he's just
like a man but Gabrielle like she
eventually like learns from her mistake
and she learns the hard way
and like all Carrie had to do was like
fall into your and we felt sorry for her
like Gabrielle goes through it right and
I know what it's amazing like I really
remember nothing but I obviously can't
forget the season like that spins up in
five years later and gabby has I gained
too much weight and it's like a house
mom and like heads no life and like I'm
not leaning forward to that because I
love like you know and it's like you
keep hoping that it's gonna be the
episode where she like takes off the fat
suit and it's not I know but but then
that'll make up for all the years of her
making bodies murder what is I see
semper Immigration and Customs
Enforcement
Immigration and Customs Enforcement I'm
glad I didn't I didn't know that one
like it's not like it was on the tip of
my tongue yeah no it's no uh FBI it's no
nobody investor it's no FEMA what's the
assembler federal emergency medical
assistance Association I don't know
speaking of IC e teresa giudice husband
Joe Giudice ordered to be deported to
Italy Wow this story like the headline
didn't sink in until it just reading it
right now Teresa Giudice husband Joe
Giudice has been ordered to be deported
to his native Italy radar Online reports
so please take that with a grain of salt
even though Us Weekly picked it up and
I'm trusting us weekly I trust bet I
think I trust weekly I trust weekly but
if radar line is the original source
like I don't know I guess so I mean
they've been saying this since the day
he went to prison that it was always an
option like it might happen so it's not
like they made this up I wonder what
happened and he's in the middle of his
sentence right so why I thought they
would decide it when it's over so there
was a hearing this morning I guess based
upon the law I find you deportable and
ineligible for any kind of relief Judge
John Ellington reportedly said during a
hearing at Pennsylvania's Pennsylvania's
York immigration court on Wednesday
October 10th quote mr. Giudice no matter
how this turns out I wish you the best I
decided this case as a matter of law
according to the website Joe who
appeared via teleconference sounded
shocked as he responded I don't
understand how I can be deported on this
case if you will I was on my side I
shouldn't even be here right now I have
to go back and tell my kids this and
they've been waiting to hear from me oh
my god this is so sad but letting you
know what like if there was any other
scenario and he did get deported like
there they love Italy like though it
wouldn't be the worst that they have to
go live in Italy but Lisa has this life
here and they're like a celebrity and
that's their income and they can't leave
I don't think she's gonna leave and also
like she's not and there were all those
unfounded rumors about her having a
boyfriend and then like basically being
divorced ready right and I never saw
from anywhere credible me neither but
maybe if that is all true then maybe he
goes back to Italy but that's just said
for the kid the kids like loved him so
much
even though he's like the meanest
scariest out alive
nope he's miss Carey's husband I feel
like he's a dad but like he's the
t-statistic Canarian they love him like
it's melted yet so much well you always
need like a strong bad cop yeah I will
totally be bad cop I
I hope I'm gonna be bad cop because I
know it's not gonna be Zach no yeah cuz
like I could see it already with Thea
because like it's not just I would love
to have Theo sleep in my bed every night
and sometimes I do for so many reasons
he can neither of us sleep good us or
Theo like he gets up a million times he
hates it
he loves his crate dogs spending more
time in the crate is good for their like
behavioral whatever and he doesn't even
like it so when we're going to bed and
like it's time to put the you in the
crate like Ben is always like let him
stay alone and say let him say and I'm
like I would love to but like I can't
and they already see like I have to be
bad cop and put the you and the crate
even though I'm really good cop Chris
the old loves is great I miss the of so
much I was gonna bring him today but
it's always torture when he's here right
nick is here so would I say he was a
torture I'm saying that we need to get
him a crate for a while I'm like we just
need to do it here yeah yeah a little
home for during mccrane but he barked
last time that was the issue Wow
that's right to take madam walk him
around he needs to bark after the here
in the fast side stories well if only he
could bark on command when I had like
some some handyman in my apartment this
weekend and they were like wow with he's
such a good dog we've never seen that
like he doesn't even bargain like please
you don't even know the nightmare that
he is when you leave I'm gonna I'll see
you later tonight I was tweeting night I
had this [ __ ] out of him today last
night like it's like I was with him all
day and I like I was too busy to like
care and then like right when I got into
bed like I was ready to give him all my
attention and he was just like over me
cuz like when it gets to like nine
o'clock he is sleepy mixtli person and
like just kind of Theo cuz you could
pull him and hold him and he doesn't
care and like oh my god I was literally
like singing licking into his mouth like
I was being so does God saying cutie boy
I miss him I miss him too let's leave
the show and go find him okay I think I
could safely turn that comments on now
like um just to close the book on this
I'm sure there'll be more updates
throughout time and you know this will
play out on the show but this is just
really sad obviously you do the crime
you have to pay the time they even
they've been doing the time you know so
well for another blow on top of this
after like years in prison and like
separating their family like it's a lot
she's like the strongest person of all
time of all time I don't know how she
does it all time um and I just I feel
for the kids and their family and like
that's so true like at the end of the
day I mean your thing is like your can
it's the changing of the seasons yeah
even though it's 70° even though they
did a terrible thing and they stole from
the government like i sended the je they
didn't kill anyone
and the only crime the only victim in
this crime was like the government and
you know what they probably needed it
the government so it's like this seems
like a really like mean thing to do like
after separating the family for almost
four years now because Teresa was in for
15 months and he's gonna be in for 3 3
years yeah it's like separating the
families for so long making them they
paid restitution every dollar that she
made from Bravo for a while was
literally going straight to the
government like I feel like they learned
their lesson and it's not gonna Freddy
why do they have to send him away this
just seems like excessive but I'm maybe
we don't understand like the full extent
of what they did and maybe the surprise
upon these particular students they're
getting off scot-free because they're
celebrities like they really give right
paid the piper no but like if there was
a Ponzi scheme and they were like taking
from people's life savings like I would
be like yeah [ __ ] um
but maybe the government takes an extra
personally like it's against a see every
time you do something against the
government like you're worse I mean it's
like the situation right so Joe we can
ask Ted was here yesterday and I asked
him because like he's close with them
and he's going to their wedding oh my
gosh I'm getting married before he goes
to prison yeah he wouldn't tell me but
something afterwards I'll tell you there
he said is in north New Jersey maybe if
we just drive around we'll find us and
it's like the thing with the situation
is when the news came out like we posted
on Instagram like a sad situation for
the situation and people in the comments
were like this isn't sad like justice
being served blah blah blah but it's
like he's already been through so much
like yeah he abated his taxes but it's
like a victimless crime also like John
said you haven't thought about it he's
not changed so much like he went to such
extremes to change his life to the point
where it probably would not happen again
and for some very sorry
right you know the same man he was and
if the judge just watched a few episodes
of Jersey Shore like maybe he'd feel
differently and it's just like I feel
like nobody can make a mistake anymore
and obviously like if you've done
something we're like you killed someone
like okay you don't deserve to be
forgiven but like something like this
it's like okay guess you technically did
it but I don't think that if you evade
your taxes you're a bad person like I've
thought about it many times and I'm
getting really close to just evading the
[ __ ] out of them well in addition to
evading his taxes they did like
fraudulent documents like make it and
they like set up cash deals like they
went out of their way they
extremes honestly though the government
drove him there and they're driving me
there too in a [ __ ] limousine in a
Range Rover let's say yeah the using all
that money or not paying on taxes right
only the best for me in the government
okay next story finally American a more
American Music Awards 2018 winners
that's a mouthful the 2018 AMA Awards is
officially here I mean we're officially
I'm sorry Tracee Ellis Ross why we
haven't even spoken about that returns
to host the annual ceremony known by pop
culture fanatics is the music industry's
largest fan voted award show this time
around cardi B and Drake led the
nominations with eight mentions each
other notable AMA contenders include
Taylor Swift at cheering Camilla Kibeho
and post Malone the winners artist of
the year Taylor Swift new artist of the
year Camilla Kibeho
collaboration of the year Camila Cabello
Havana favorite music video Camila
kebaya Habano tour of the Year Taylor
Swift favorite soundtrack Black Panther
favorite male artists post Malone
favorite female artist Taylor Swift
favorite do our group me dos so we know
that every award show is literally fake
as [ __ ] and they align themselves with
like a certain side like they take a
side like the VMAs were Ariana's and she
won all the awards right there like
Taylor if you come to this award show
you'll open the show you'll get three
awards making you the most celebrated
American Music Award person ever 24 for
three she won ya mister before the third
put her over the top yes is us as the
winner so of course she's gonna show up
to make history but if she didn't show
up she probably wouldn't want all those
awards no of course not like it's all
pre organized but that just is annoying
because I really also feel like every
award that Taylor won like she deserved
like in no way could anyone disagree
with Taylor's tour being the tour of the
I mean everyone even people who hate
Taylor went and loved it like so it's
just annoying that like we're talking it
up to it all being vacant if she didn't
come she wouldn't have won which is true
but she did deserve it well here's the
thing there was like one award that was
like a best male artist or something or
a male R&B artist and there was three
people nominated which by the way which
award show has three people in each
category and it was someone someone in
Bruno Mars and they didn't even say
Bruno Mars because it was like they
forgot him in the package because he
wasn't there like
no way he was winning how figure less
they are also Bruno Mars was nominated
in the tour of the year as was ed
Sheeran and as you know my thoughts on
the Ed Sheeran show in no way does he
deserve to win but if anyone else had to
have won it would have been Bruno Mars
and I would have agreed with it I
would've been sad for Taylor but like he
really did have and he's still on the
tour but like the it wasn't the tour
that's the tour of the year it's like
he's the artist of all time like
Taylor's tour she really went like big
so thought out what the theme is like
there yeah this staging the reverie link
was so sought out like all Bruno Mars
has to do is like show us with his
hooligans you have a great time drink go
home no he needs to start doing a show
in Vegas I mean I will move okay I'm
trying to convince Olivia to do her
bachelorette party in Vegas you are yeah
and I because she's just like it's so
expensive because like everything you
want to do like where I'm knowing we
have to have like the best table and I
said totally I'll do everything I can to
try and get some calm so if you like
working biggest marketing talent hit hit
me up but and then I was like we could
also go to Celine Dion so like maybe
let's all convince her oh I'm down I'm
so down I just like a long flight and
Vegas as far and Vegas takes it all from
me no but like that's what we need
we wouldn't work I mean personally I've
been working so much for like six months
straight that like from someone who
never used to work and like never did
anything to like literally someone who's
like I go to bed at midnight on my
computer and I wake up and I'm ah my
computer like I don't stop [ __ ]
working and look physically working
traveling like I want to go to Vegas and
I want to black out and I want to get
new titties like that's what I want to
do for sure and I deserve it I want to
do like acid I don't know I just want to
do something what I'm so [ __ ] wound
up by the way like doing this is nice
day today doing acid his work - oh my
god are you kidding me I would never do
ask him imagine you just leave that
loose on acid well then I got try
parties in two weeks and you can really
let those tote that up but it's a
different vibe than Vegas we're going in
the Bahamas I'm so excited but I also
like I'm gonna sweat so like the pool
but like knowing that sweating is in my
future like it does give me like it
takes a little edge off like my pit but
swimming well well I was just telling
Jackie because I'm ordering clothes for
your bachelorette party which is put me
to be so difficult because like I'm in
it's like weird interim size now and you
know when you like lose a little weight
you like think that you are like Taylor
Swift at the
like the [ __ ] that I ordered like boohoo
is like very hoochie and when I when I
order from it like you have to be
selected like this sweater is from but
it's obviously not hoochie but like it's
not there's how much should I say it can
be misrepresented yeah there knock their
[ __ ] it's like fashion Nova knock-offs
so like I'm going through this stuff
like now thinking that I'm actually no
that's easy right now I'm like ordering
like thinking I'm like this is skinny
Queen which like I'm definitely like
less fat but I'm by knowing skinny and
I'm out of control like you are you are
going to die when you see some of the
things that I ordered because it's also
like it's a bachelorette petition you
can be huije right so Bahamas you can be
hoochie and like now I lost little bit
weights like I can really do G so I'm
gonna be out of control
good that what's the point like what's
the point of working so hard losing
weight if you're not gonna show it off
take it all so what's the point
it's a bachelor party it's all girls
like everyone can eat my ass totally I
hope there's some fights on your
bachelor party I got into a fight with
someone a long time oh maybe who do you
think I don't know that's not what I was
anticipating I thought that actually
like all your friends are friends it's
not like weird camp home homes but where
do we do go to job that in our family
like everyone is friends like the same
people be on my Bachelorette that are on
Olivia yes sir
good times can't wait so many work I
still turned to Olivia to do New Orleans
I want to go to Charleston and by the
way they're filming southern charm like
she doesn't want to go to Charleston she
doesn't know and I was like I was
against it cuz I'm supposed to go to LA
afterwards I mean also I got tickets on
Sunday to go see god O'Malley in New
York oh I'm excited I don't know why I
just remember that but I'm happy for you
me do uh sorry sad note she doesn't want
to go anymore
okay so we got everything we should go
to Napa okay that's what I said it I
also said in Naples because I always
tell me am I wrong I thought Naples
Florida was like the Napa of Florida
like the vineyards and [ __ ] oh I don't
know about vineyard like its Fort
Lauderdale what is he's like granny I
thought it was we may as well go to Boca
I thought it was literally like Napa of
the East Coast Vineyard City no I told
Olivia a weird call and I think she
didn't like the idea but Montreal TPG
said Montreal it's like the newest
coolest up-and-coming city really and
they have gambling that's what Olivia
said what about the grace Mayflower oh
that's where we should go totally but
it's not turnip and Olivia doesn't want
to turn up like that's where you should
go cuz you're a grandmother's days no
but I'm gonna turn on
actually I don't know I'm just loving
not drinking like a million bucks even
though I'm sick actually I feel like
[ __ ] all the time I was in the city
that's good drink even when I take care
of myself I still feel tired and groggy
and shitty so like I might as well have
a good time that I perform the other day
I woke up with a headache like I
hangover but I didn't drink someone I
woke up with a headache this morning
because I've my period and I have been
just like having the worst mood swings
like I don't know why I feel like I've
been getting my period my whole life but
like this one in particular it's like
it's almost like it's the first one no
exciting work right now would have been
twins yes I'm getting the worst cramps
last night like literally right before
bed I was having a worst belly ache and
Ben was like gentle rub your belly and
I'm like yeah and he like kind of hurt
me like he was like oh I think I feel a
cramp like as if you could [ __ ] feel
a cramp and starts digging and I it sent
me a set a [ __ ] switch off in my head
and I was I was being nuts I was
honestly I have to apologize to Ben this
morning because I was being so evil and
I was just in the worst [ __ ] mood and
it like set this light off in me and
like I couldn't go to bed I was too
[ __ ] busy being so angry and mean and
I owe that a huge apology you need to
get a heating pad you know of course I
have a heating pad that I literally
ready you know what I did I rolled it up
into a little sausage like shoved it in
my stomach in my pants and went to bed
and woke up in the biggest sweat of my
life it's like I can't witness that the
two hour timer like you need one with
the timer it turns on automatically
it's from [ __ ] Duane Reade like you
got to get one from Amazon I don't know
what kind of best gold-plated investing
yourself I totally know I don't know
what I was thinking are you thinking pad
every night now and I'm like I wanna go
to eating blanket that I put under my
sheet but that's really hot I know you
see the little pad and then like if you
fall asleep on your stomach put it under
your stomach and thus the best way to
fall asleep yeah well you're in pain I
love a heating pad for my back I have
like a bad back these days because I
travel so much and like fall asleep on
planes and I'm like a grandma like I
been down to like I'm like a grandma
using microwave I been down to get my
glow dryer and like oh my a key Behati
like a 2 euro that I make when they do
stuff and like or I'm just I'm a
grandmother but that's not surprising
I'm surprised for you because you're
really like in the prime of your life
that's what I'm saying even though
yesterday I got called old for the first
time I hey look I got aegis in our good
tax member oh right someone's
screenshotted yesterday I felt very old
watching the AME
oh my god and I didn't mind it yeah no
award shows are like always what makes
me feel out of touch even though we
couldn't be more in touch right so I
don't know what it is it's like are they
just propping these people up cuz it's
their agenda then they want to move them
forward or there used to be a time I
mean if I looked at the iTunes top 10
like there was no way I didn't know one
song right I don't know and I don't
really don't know most of them and I
think that's that's on me yes I'm
growing up like I can't live in the past
wait I have to tell you about my Jay
yesterday because I did my closet right
oh my god it was the best decision I
ever made you pay for it no so I'm doing
you know a partnership okay
it's a company called done and done and
when they email me they're like we just
did Bethenny's and that's how like I
knew it was good enough for me and if
they have like a team of like 10 15
people but it was started by this mom
and daughter and they're the ones who
came and they were like so cute and just
so good at their job and so fast and
basically like all my clothes I have
this big closet and then for the folding
stuff in my bedroom I have like this
built-in unit where everything is folded
and like obviously like I just threw it
in there like never looked back
and I really only wanted them to come
and do the closet cuz like that's what
people can see and like I don't care if
I shove things in the cabinets they did
so fast that they had so much time and
they did my folded stuff too they
labeled every shelf Ben's sweatpants
clàudia Spanx
I have like four rows of space now you
have to keep it that way oh I'm fine I
can do that like I am a neat person yeah
but Ben is like I'm I literally had to
give him a lecture I was like if you
touch one [ __ ] thing in this closet I
will kill you and like what do I do I
wake up and I find the shirt on the
floor they made it so nice for him they
did my whole bags in this display they
utilized all the space like I have only
amazing things to say I've been
recommending them to everyone the
company was called done and done like I
and by the way I didn't lift a finger
which was my favorite part like I didn't
have to do anything I'm like you guys
one help they're like notes guy I'm okay
I feel like I could do that for people I
could have done that for you okay so I
thought the same thing because I'm so
organized and they would like for
closets specifically yes my closet I
built my own shells and I I don't know
that they could have done my closet
better than I did okay but here's the
thing here's what they had that I
couldn't that I was like I really hired
a company cuz like I'm like I could do
this and like go to the Container Store
and [ __ ] but like I don't want you I'm
Thai understand so then once it
and I was like oh I never could have
done this because first of all they had
the foresight to categorize all my
hanging stuff by color and then by what
it is so it's like all my tank tops are
in it's not like red orange yellow green
blue purple across the whole rod it's a
red tank short sleeves long sleeves yeah
yeah and then a whole other jackets
sweaters separated by outerwear like he
was so specific and it makes so much
sense and then I was like I've been
trying to find a cool way to display my
bags forever and I never would have
thought to get these like acrylic like
leveled shelves that they got so like I
couldn't have ever done that like I'm
only my organization can only take me so
much and then I would have put all my
bags but they put all like my flat
envelope like clutches like this Tony
clover one sore left that Gucci went
back on me and it's a cute Bhavan basket
somewhere else like yeah it all makes so
much sense and then what I couldn't have
done 10 times is we have these huge shoe
racks and for been the shoe racks really
don't make something that much sense
because they have their of these little
platforms and you supposed to put your
heels on it and it makes it a cute
display for your heels but then pretty
much wear of sneakers he has like a
couple pairs of loafers that work on
there but he has all this space and
there's nowhere to put it
and he also has all these hats that like
I I saw that yeah she made this whole
display and then brought this other
built-in thing from the Container Store
to put in one of the things for Ben's
sneakers genius like I couldn't have
done that so I mean I don't know how
much it costs regularly whatever it was
I would have done it because so worth it
I'm so happy for you and also you
telling me those tips and tricks that's
what I did in mind like do be elevated
stuff and I feel really good proud now
I'm gonna go to the Container Store like
all the time hit me up right hit me up
sis okay
next story Kim Kardashian plots wants
diamonds and security detail do you see
last night she brought you in for some
serious diamonds to a Tiffany's event on
Tuesday night she was definitely paid to
be there but no of course by the way
she's wearing Tiffany's items like
please don't even try but he just felt
like so a little off-brand because she's
so anti jewelry right because you know
she's so happy that her kids were
getting to grow up with this version of
her right that interview that she did
with Ellen after her robbery in Paris
like will always be like I see things
with Taylor like who I stand completely
that like are an insight to really who
she is as a person like all the
charities she does like really quietly
like giving literally 3,000 tickets like
the families of firefighters and
policemen in Boston and this interview
with cam is like I feel like a rare
glimpse into like who she really is like
as a person and I will
remember that interview understand I
always wondered when she was gonna wear
jewelry again and I'm glad that she did
it and got paid for it of course
the reality TV star lit took to
Instagram to flaunt a massive diamond
choker and several diamond rings
something she's rarely done since being
robbed in Paris in 2016 but Kardashian
was quick to point out her security was
beefed up just in case anyone tried to
get too close she's so funny quote look
at these jewels I get to borrow for the
night the mom of three said in the
backseat of her ride zooming around New
York City I have security with me and
they the Diamonds leave me after the
night I turn into Cinderella
Tiffany's led the jewels to the stars so
she could wear them to their blue book
collection event Kris Jenner and mary j
blige were also on hand for the glitzy
event I saw that on Simon's insurance
story and it's like I just saw Simon and
like then he saw Kris and Kim like I
couldn't have been at the same time
oh damn so one day one day just keep on
truckin well I feel like ship eni's is
like spending a lot of money recently
like their whole thing with Reese
Witherspoon like they're just like they
know what they're in tune yeah and I
feel like there's their modernization
everyone know I was pulling on the mic
cord out of my legs oh do you know how
many people were the Jackie O sweater to
my show in Huntsville really yeah and
Albany jus I hope I wonder if they
should I miss selling them again this
season it's the best sweater ever I want
more colors I have like five I need more
the chose just sold out so many items we
sold out that Revlon blow-dryer that
changed my life oh yeah one no but I was
with um Zach's friends the other night
after the fair and one of them was like
I bought Claudia's blow dryer this blow
dryer it's fifty nine dollars retail but
I think is a fair price for a bill
lifesaver that it is and I'm so worried
it's gonna like be discontinued I don't
know why I like I want to get it yes and
then Ulta and it on sale for $29 it's
out of stock now like the toasters in
the beauty and the toast who put it out
of stock and like I just want Revlon to
know that like that was me and someone
you don't understand like as someone
have you notice that my hair has been
straight almost every day like since
this phone I don't have good hair no
totally but like not all the time and
you can't rely on it cuz I like to
shower at night and by the time I wake
up my hair is still wet like yeah and
for the shows like I used to book hair
and makeup in every city like I'm fine
random people on Instagram and it was so
expensive and so time-consuming I'm like
so infuriating because I never liked it
this blow dryer ask Margo all I do is
talk about this blow dryer on tour it
has changed my life for Olivia's
engagement party like a time when I
normally what I've gotten a blow dryer
blowout I did my own okay
I'm gonna get it and for you like your
hair you've so much less hair than me
you could blow out your hair like to
look like it is right now
in five minutes it takes me 15 which is
so crazy but for me it's not like the
time it takes it's like getting up and
doing it like jogging but it's this one
like I get excited it's so we you know
how like when you get something new like
for the first week I said yeah I've had
it for like two months now and I'm so
excited and it makes it so easy because
I don't like flat straight hair I like
to have like a little bounce at the
bottom but because of its Rolly
technique you just twist a medium sound
oh my god it's the best okay I you've
sold me thank you
okay next story ready for this uh-oh the
page was loaded
if Jackie has a virus on her iPad no you
know what I realized it's only its page
six comm that gives me a virus oh yes
every other website is fine the openness
to do they like give me some I guess I'm
a big winner of some Amazon gift cards
it's a good question from Christine what
is your natural hair well it's weird
because like growing up my natural hair
was like so curly and he's like jealous
run shake it even curlier and then I
started ironing it and doing it every
single day so now my natural hair
doesn't really have a shape to it it's
like the ends are straight cuz they're
dead the top is like wavy in the middle
is wavy too I feel like it's it your
natural hair is like what it is now just
like not as shiny not as no it's shiny
no not shiny um not as like sleek yeah
it's like a little just like with like a
little curtain yeah curly or the back is
a little curly but like it's just it's
kind of it's almost like waiting to be
played with it doesn't really take shape
it's like we know we're not staying this
way have you ever worn your natural hair
like on the show yes it down um perhaps
definitely in a ponytail I've worn it
and then how many times a week do you
shower and redo it depends on the season
but I probably and if I'm like working
out or if I just wash it like when it
starts to smell but that's gonna be two
days that can be four days right it's
very similar they wash my hair two times
a week or three times a week okay cuz
now I'm like this person where like I'm
constantly thinking of my hair where I
used to shower every night and if I
didn't I would get oily season so now
I'm like building up an immunity to the
oil and now I can go I'll usually like
do my hair Sunday night for the week and
then Wednesday and then maybe Saturday
morning shower I really just have to
wash my hair one witness doesn't really
get greasy but it starts to hurt like
when I flip it over like the follicles
really hurt from me in the same place
for too long and I have to massage it
out and I let her scalp massage I mean
love it so much Emer got massages in the
Atlanta Airport and the second I sat
down on that chair she cracked my back
in two places and I want
- literally kiss her on the lips it felt
so good oh my god tell us now I'm
actually pretty good
I'll never forgot how I felt after camp
toast and I just compared everything to
that means like I'm able to walk I'm
okay
me and Margo wouldn't we were getting
our massages we're like our backs have
literally been [ __ ] up since camped I
was like I just I gave it my all
I mean and the beds yeah but next year
I'm buying a duck Siana totally for my
semantics yes host okay next story Busy
Philipps
says quote bully James Franco pushed her
to the ground while filming freak sneaks
Busy Philipps doesn't have the fondest
memories of working with James Franco in
her forthcoming memoir this will only
hurt a little the actress details an
incident she claims occurred on a
particularly tense day on the set of
freaks and each which aired on NBC from
1999 to 2000 the excerpt was first
reported by radar online Philip this is
a big day for radar Online Philips
claims in the books that Franco whom she
describes as a quote [ __ ] bully [ __ ]
perhaps didn't treat her with the same
level of respect that he reserved for
Linda Cardellini and all of his male
co-stars illustrating one example where
the actor was especially difficult to
work with she recalled their experience
shooting the we've got spirit episode
after shooting one seamer Phillips said
she called out Franco for stepping on
her stepping on her line stepping on one
of her lines the pair who played a
couple had to shoot a scene where
Phillips was supposed to hit Franco in
the chest
however instead of responding with a
dialogue Phillips claimed that instead
her co-star quote grabbed both my arms
and screamed in my face don't ever touch
me again
she wrote that he proceeded to throw her
to the ground knocking the wind out of
her so I was have you ever seen freaks
engaged yes and the next day Phillips
said Franco apologized to her after
executive producer Judd Apatow made him
watch a video of what happened Oh cuz
everything's on camera it's just a funny
cause like that was 1999 like the
footage is definitely lost but if that
was today like it would have gone viral
right and like Kris Jenner would have
you know meticulously said to that via
TMZ
I'm James Franco like would maybe have
been taken down but he like is an
immovable force is Iron Man no like no
no accusations can take this man down he
still gets work it's so crazy and it's
annoying because as someone who watched
freaks and geeks like I know first of
all the greatest show I can't believe it
only had one season but obviously was
deeply problematic behind the scenes and
now we know why it only left once he
said I only watched a few episodes but
there was only one season I at that
point it was a great show like Linda
Cardellini being on it because like
she's the og chutney is just so funny
and she
kind of Mickey to come back Linda
cordially I mean she's in everything
yeah she a million's no she's a madman
same thing so this is not shocking but I
just think this is such like not to be
insensitive or anything but like this is
such great press for business book like
everyone's talking about it I've seen
this thing everywhere is he's booking
busy show right they were talking about
on a news but then she clarified on
Instagram she said the Franco story is
used to illustrate a larger point about
the way women are treated in this
business in life there are no
allegations and no accusations it's a
story that I've been telling for years
James apologized I accepted and I still
got to tell it because it [ __ ]
happened to me
right so she they were on a panel once
about another project that like a couple
people on the panel who were also in
Freaks and Geeks and busy alluded to it
again and it was like to show awkward
I'd watched a video of it and because
James was on the panel it was just
awkward so she's she's told this story
many times and I don't know if like her
and James are friends I'm gonna assume
no but crazy crazy she said my book is
300 meet pages not one paragraph aka buy
it great right
no I mean that's annoying that people
are focusing on this one thing but maybe
it's just not that interesting I mean
any presses is good president and it's a
true story and it's written in her book
so that's what people decide to pick up
on people if that's the most salacious
detail by the way yeah I don't know if
it's a must read
so when Leah Remini is book about
Scientology came out obviously I didn't
buy it or read it cuz I hate reading
books but BuzzFeed did this amazing like
here you don't to read the whole thing
like here's we read it and this is the
craziest that like [ __ ] that to come out
of it
and it was so interesting about like
some Tom Cruise like not knowing how to
bake cookies and like alphas assistants
like they can't correct him so like
whatever was great and I feel like if
there was more interesting things in the
Busy Philipps book like most people
different nothing about it right but
then also like Holly Madison wrote her
memoir and there was another one of
those aliases tickles things you need to
know but then I read the book too
because I was like so curious and I got
it for free at work and I wanted
something to do and there really was so
much more like sometimes it's really
worth reading the book it's like what
they think is interesting isn't what's
interesting it's like reading between
the lines and that's some weird anecdote
sometimes it's just like on the reunions
like right it's like Cindy's books right
it's like the main storyline is obvious
but sometimes it's what's bubbling
beneath the surface right like Andy's
books there's a good amount of like
obvious drama but like to me the more
interesting thing is like the phone call
yeah but the househusband
from OC who just got fired he's begging
and
his wife back cuz he quit his job like
who was it I believe it was Jim Bellino
that just sounds like a Jim Bellino move
yeah but you never know maybe it was uh
Frank and and Lydia a little net yeah
that's not her name but what's up Liddy
no it's a Lynette no that's that's is
cava its Lin Lin yeah they were really
sad like that oh my god it was sad they
started filming a reality show at the
worst possible time in their lives
she was foreclosed on national
television and her daughter was like so
obnoxious without her nose member I mean
yeah terrible but she makes cameos
randomly live yeah
Oh see your bad OC is so bad I
physically like I can't take it on no I
refuse
I just keep up with it because it's it's
the job it's easy to keep up with
because there's not much going on right
it's like a lull for Bravo right now
like everything's kind of quiet
Dallas is poppin below-deck is poppin
nobody look Beverly Hills and New York
are both not on so and when that's our
like the big hitters and Atlanta is
coming back and I feel I intend on being
like the best Atlanta watcher I always
start and like eventually just like
forget or catch up like randomly I'm
gonna be on it because I feel like it's
gonna be really good I feel like it's
always really good my problem is is that
I miss so much back in the day I think
like when I was in college that I don't
know the history and I can't understand
the show now if I don't know the history
like I can't take sides now if I don't
know what they're reading about and like
who's really right you know and like
even though like some of them are cool
they've all not been cool previously
right and I'm sure they've all done
unforgivable things yeah so I need to
know all of that in order to understand
the current season so either I have to
binge watch every season which would be
good which would wouldn't be bad um or I
have to or I could watch it but I can't
have really strong opinions about it
because I don't know well real um
responded to my Instagram story last
night did you give her tickets to your
show yet and what did she say to your
Instagram well I put up a picture of I
photoshopped myself into a picture of
her and Kim and it's like this is how
I'm trying to be in Atlanta this weekend
because I was promoting my show because
it's an 1,100 person theater and look
we're at 900 tickets I'm like we're so
close so like tickets available at
Carl's gonna chop tack on bring your
friend family dog I don't care just like
buy one and don't even come I'll give
you $25
and it was just like a funny picture and
they didn't even tag them I didn't wanna
be thirsty
me when it when's the show Friday and we
Margaery leaving Friday morning if you
want to call me con cop it okay maybe I
will come then might come also so I need
to have another hotel room just let me
know okay and Olivia might come to
Atlanta me oh no it just like scouted
for the Super Bowl right even though you
know I can't come right no I know but
I'm not accepting that okay umm not
accepting it should I give her tickets I
gave Heather McMahon two tickets who are
other like local ATL slabs so many
showed a me right now uh the cast of
dynasty I'm gonna test Christian yeah
Liz okay but know what shade we know you
have to think about you can't just be so
hasty but what do you mean I want to do
it already you're gonna do okay you're
gonna DM her right now
wait where is it she'll send oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh no okay she said
I'm a week lol um okay how do I say I'm
like how do comics me like I'm taking my
tour Atlanta right they say I'm playing
a show okay but what if she thinks
you're a musician like she doesn't write
okay um I'm doing a show i have a show
I'm doing I don't know doing a show
sounds like you're just like part of a
burlesque show right or like a traveling
West Broadway show or like peaking of
off-broadway dove Cameron clueless I
mean what dove Cameron is moving to New
York to star a share in the off-broadway
rendition of clueless which is an
inspired choice and I'm so excited I
don't know why it's off Broadway but
it's gonna be amazing she's so talented
and I just wanna hear that it's also
written by the person who wrote clueless
so I could tillage it thing I just don't
know why it's off Broadway like it's
like Mean Girls the same writer that's
off Broadway maybe that's to start off
Broadway I will be on opening night
I'll be there I don't care sure but it
won't be that crazy because it's
off-broadway and like we love to have
Cameron but most of her fans like don't
really even have wallet but it was so
good she oh she instagrammed oh good she
was I mean you get a phone call like
that changed her life and just pick up
and move to New York and then all of a
sudden she's here right because she's
starting to share her wits in the
off-broadway rendition of clueless which
is just the best thing I've ever heard
okay definitely idea okay you know I
want to say like it's legit like I'm at
a theater so toasters you can comment
like what you think might be a cool way
to be like how do you as reference the
Sandy Springs City Center do I call it
the whole things I just say cities
like how do I say they wonder no it's
like not like a sad thing hey I'm
bringing my torta up to Atlanta is that
weird I'm bringing might or might or
might or is it like my tour sounds legit
but I don't know how these people talk
right into know and I don't wanna make
it seem like I'm trying so hard but I
also like want her to know I'm like I'm
literally playing a show yeah I'm
playing a show in Atlanta on Friday
I'm Friday night at City Springs what
are they saying about Sandy Springs you
guys what do you say Sandy Springs City
Center the city center Sandy Springs
sscc okay so far this is what I sweated
the camps call and playing a show in
Atlanta on Friday night I'd standings
from city centre you should come I'm
gonna be like how do I say like I'll
leave I'll give you tickets you have to
bother him obviously um I mean maybe you
say that in the follow-up like seeing
what she says maybe she's not even
around they should be like yeah maybe
I'll stop by and be like yeah tickets
will be for you let me know I'll lead
you tickets alcohol yeah let me know how
many six tickets you need I'll leave
them at welcome mat so you said this I'm
playing you shown Atlanta on Friday
night at any Spring City Center you
should come um okay some people are
saying playing sounds like you're
playing an instrument let's talk okay
say I'm going to be Atlanta in Atlanta
this Friday for my show
someone said have a I have a stand-up
show in Atlanta this Friday come stand
up I don't know I'm gonna show ya stana
sounds like open mic I agree I'm doing a
show in Atlanta on Friday at Sanna
Spring City Center you should come
you're doing is better than playing yes
yeah even though the true comics do see
playing but whatever it's I I guess I
sent it yeah just send it shoot your
shot as people say okay done what time
is it in Atlanta do you think she's
awake it's Eastern Time
oh great that makes it easy from 10:30
a.m. Eastern oh my China see people
won't be able to come because dynasties
on that night yeah so so they have to
watch it this series premiere oh it's
the premiere yeah maybe they're doing
press they don't have to watch it I mean
they might be doing press oh my god I've
so many shows to catch up on I need a
bunch of new blue bloods I need to catch
Housewives of Dallas I've been catching
up on this because I'm like three
episodes behind and I caught up on the
last two and it is so boring like even
though shit's happening I'm thinking I'm
like this is boring yeah it's it's not
like bad but nothing's really happening
yet next this last
episode seemed to be the big one I don't
know I just feel like sometimes it's me
like if I'm not enjoying something I
think it's like I'm not right but I want
to be a Dallas fan and I want to keep up
and know what's going on so like I'm
watching but like I couldn't care less
like when I have a new Kardashians in my
DVR like I turn on turning off all my
devices putting my glasses on and
turning the lights off you have to watch
this visa I know I will watch it tonight
and we will do this I'm so conflicted
and like so many interesting things
happened like Chris like buys her friend
a facelift and it was just like so
interesting with Sheila and it was like
why can't she get her own facelift like
is she like the poor friend right but it
just seemed like maybe she just doesn't
prioritize herself right oh yeah or like
she wouldn't have done it if it wasn't a
gift right look Sheila and they show you
like they go to lunch with her like
after her recovery so you really seem to
shield their friends yes she does I
don't feel good so it's just very
interesting okay fifth and final story
some business news because we want to
keep you guys up to date so you can like
go on dates go on interviews and just
like you know what's going on in the
world of course of course
Sears may be days away from bankruptcy
this is kind of really sad because Sears
is like in an institution and if
honestly if Regina George couldn't save
it then nobody can the handwriting is on
the wall
Sears appears to be nearing bankruptcy
one of Sears is mayor major shareholders
just dumped a chunk of his stock for
pennies on his original investment it
sucks the company added a new director
who was familiar with bankruptcies in
restructuring reports circulated that
the company is talking to advisors and
banks in preparation for a bankruptcy
filing Sears Holdings the parent company
of Sears and Kmart faces in October 15th
deadline to pay one hundred and thirty
four million dollars on its debt CEO and
primary shareholder Ellie Lampert told
the company's board that it was crucial
that it was crucial at restructure more
than five billion dollars it owes quote
without delay according to a recent
regulatory filing like how does a
company like this get into five billion
dollars it's like you sell products you
make money and while you don't you close
a store right like what if CEO would let
you go into five billion dollar debt
right it's like what kind of money are
you laying out for like new TVs right
and but honestly like all I can think
about is like they're going out of
business sales on TVs fridges appliances
that are normally doing like I said like
I don't know she's just buy a bunch of
[ __ ] and like keep it in a warehouse
yeah I mean I mean been like did one a
huge TV and are the one me up now I was
like seventy which is big like we really
want to actually you probably drive way
bigger one
have the space right you should do it
but we had like a 70-inch one so we
didn't feel like getting rid of it but
if sears is having some bomb bankruptcy
sales I could be down
investors are giving up hope on a deal
Sears Holdings stock plunge 28%
Wednesday the stock has lost two-thirds
of its already depressed value since
Lampert announced the attempt to
restructure the company's debt on
September 24th this is like sad no this
is really sad because Sears is it's just
a lot of people who will lose their jobs
like that's what's sad like everyone who
works out of ceará works for Sears
delivery Sears truckdrivers Sears
cashier Sears to corporate like that is
sad that's really sad
someone's got to get in there and turn
it around maybe Elon Musk or someone
will buy Sears prop it up right Amazon
they need to sue me Amazon should buy
Sears Sears is a bad name yeah they need
a reader shirts a family name but Sears
like first of all it's weird to say and
then it's like okay if I could get into
something Mac stigma like you could try
Sears it right over then and the Tina
Fey is responsible if you know but if
you could try if you could buy a TV or
okay if you could buy a fridge from a
place called Home Depot Sears does home
keep ourself wrenches yeah PC Richard do
they solve another bad name terrible and
I can't believe they see any business
but they use change they're not tricky
they're not nearly as big they're I
think they're like regional they're like
suppose for sure we only know that you
know I don't think everyone knows that
Walmart right like Target Walmart Best
Buy or Sears what are you gonna buy
personally I think I'll get the best
deal at Walmart yeah by the way Walmart
is the greatest or alive but I was in I
was talking more just like the name the
name yet no Sears isn't out there I
don't identify with Sears can you help
me with some things we have home decor
so I'm getting like an entry
consultation or respect my opinions now
that I did my own apartment yes but it's
more so about the money because I feel
like you really keep me in check like
with my finances cuz you don't like so
cheap and then randomly like but I also
tell you when to splurge wait okay so
tell me the spirt let me show you this
table it is so gorgeous and I found it
on me man Marcus and I need to stop
looking at Neiman Marcus home because it
is so poor child okay so also expensive
but it's you know where my kitchen door
is like that and then the hallway right
outside yeah it's a the entry on the I
would put it on the other side of the
kitchen door hallway okay the kitchen
oh that's beautiful um okay so let me
tell you [ __ ]
Neiman Marcus out-of-control is selling
it for $6,000 but I was never in my home
that you have a discount well so then I
found I was looking for it elsewhere I'm
like maybe it's on sale even if it's
overstock.com right I'm like even if
it's on sale like that's not gonna help
me give me 50% of it's still 3 know to
be like 100 percent off so you down and
watch out for 4,000 I'm like okay I'm so
lucky I got it then you know I've been
like so shady with my weird deals like
honey I'm like yeah I'm a setting you're
an interior decorating house so I got
away to get it wholesale for 2500 but
that is still like so much money and
it's not like it's a little thing it's
like a huge table like it should be
expensive like I could have I could have
spent it's an investment like it's
something that you'll take like that
will follow you so I don't know if it
goes with my take or vibe but like even
though it's in a different room it's
like I'm going with like the silver/gray
vibe but it is in a different room I
just think it would look so pretty and
like I wouldn't need anything else in
the hallway except a piece of art you
know you have a really big hallway I
know but it's huge I'm gonna say no okay
great okay I don't think you need it
like that's almost how much you spent on
your couch no totally I'm just like I
couldn't believe that I actually got it
for 25 I'm like devil now I have to get
it you know right you got it for more
than 50% right but I can't it's too much
and it's like that's not an important I
mean it is an important piece of
decorative it's not your next big
investment I agree like what an
investment but you did invest in some
things already you can't invest in
everything you got it you know I'm happy
Nilo well I got a Jonathan Adler things
like which ones the bar oh my god oh
right I totally forgot about that I have
any money the buffet but the buffet I
got an amazing price for sure but I got
two of them you got two buffets I bet
you face one of them I know that hasn't
come yet as a con yet but [ __ ] Z
Gallerie they're pissing me off with
they're shipping late September mid
October it's now October 10th whatever
and I haven't heard from them it's
really annoying and I'm getting mad
that's that's what you got
I mean of course it couldn't be it
couldn't be the first day of the late
September or it's not but it has to be
the last day of late October I said like
five days once it's here you'll never
remember when it wasn't here and just
it's no cuz when it's here it's not even
fully here one piece is gonna be missing
in the comes in December for sure but
you still have a whole couch totally and
the couch is worth it yeah and I'm doing
really it's sponsored by Z Gallerie
my dogs have a seagull or couch
Lucca couch it's the best couch it's so
funny that I went shopping for couches
left a couple months ago
coach inspired me this one couch I fell
in love with I was so excited by my
couch I never thought I'd be someone who
got excited about a cowboy and you
wanted it in beige right and I wanted in
beige and like I went beige was custom
it would take this much longer than I
started thinking maybe I could do silver
a silver vibe and I ultimately decided
on silver a few months later you go
shopping for a couch you look at every
touch in the land everywhere you see
this couch you love this couch you
decide beige you're like she had the
exact thing I wanted beige but I don't
want to wait while I would Greta my
whole color scheme is off like there's
only one good couch out there there's
one good couch it's crazy
well you'll come over today and see the
improvements but I got a Jill Zarin rug
and it's so nice and it's such good
quality and Ally told me that it's
literally made for dogs to pee on she
was like literally you take a little bit
of a wet paper towel and it's gone how
was letting my question is how does Theo
feel about it ya know and he hasn't peed
in our new house
yet but that was just like good to know
that's great to know
yeah well that was our fifth story Wow
okay well toasters we pulled some dear
toasters and I just need to check my
list and make sure I talked about all
the things I needed to talk about all
right let me know
Oh Riverdale and watch what happens live
was the only thing you said it was
boring yeah it was kind of disappointing
it was a weird crew it was Lily
KJ mädchen and Luke Perry oh that is
weird and honestly everyone was pretty
good except for Lily like she's just a
little too serious for watch out inside
there's no way she watches Bravo like no
way totally watches PBS no and she is
like a forward-thinking progressive
feminist like I bet she thinks that
housewives is bad for the feminist
movement that's backwards thinking
because it's not like you're getting
like he's given all these women lives
and jobs and agency to leave they're a
terrible husband no and he's by the way
yeah I mean we don't have to make any
grab oh is the only network that
promotes women of a certain age
literally on every other network you
have to be 12 to get work but every
housewife on Bravo I think the youngest
housewife is I think it was Meghan King
Edmonds yeah and she was like 33 yeah so
like are there yeah um so Lily was like
a little too serious for it KJ was like
really cute but they did something in a
way they opened the vault and you
wouldn't think there one's been such
good stuff they're like Lily had been on
Law & Order right who Perry has all this
crazy stuff imagine and they just like
put old pictures of them
that were taken from their instagrams
like that is so cheap
baracy yeah okay she posted those
pictures himself yeah like I really I
was disappointed and it was putting a
cornice tale like they found this clip
of Lily like from when she was a kid
like in a rap battle and KJ was dying so
funny it was really funny I wish they
did it like I love mädchen I didn't need
her her and Luke Perry like I wish they
did it with Kenny Mendes I know that
Cole would never have gone on but like
why because he's like so he's so serious
no but I feel like it's him and Lily
were there together they might have like
brought out a bet like the more he and
asked them no it's a junk show where
like you drink and it's fun and silly
Lily's way too serious for it and they
should have had mädchen and Luke Perry
Onix separately it's like I never
guessed with with other people think 902
107 yeah and it's just like I wanted a
Riverdale centric episode from what I'm
hearing from you that's not what we got
there was a lot going on and it seemed
like the things that we're at tailored
towards Riverdale specifically weren't
necessarily written by people who watch
the show of course not
so that was my that was I feel like in
another world KJ and Andy Cohen we got
along really well
I mean maybe they did after after last
night yeah KJ I love him he was so down
for every button yet also Lilly and KJ
were drinking these drinks that looks
like like smoothies like pina coladas
almost that were red and it was like
ambiguous whether they were alcoholic or
not cuz probably they don't want to like
be seen drinking but they're over 21
like give him a beer totally no they
were strawberry daiquiris and KJ
commented but I had too much Andy thing
too many daiquiris for me soon they were
alcohol and Luke Perry was like just
taking beers to the face good good I
love when people like embrace the
culture of watch happens live and
mädchen embrace like she was the perfect
guys because she's been on this so much
like iconic signs she answered every
question like she was perfect speaking
of Twin Peaks I just got to Desperate
Housewives where Orson has introduced
where you meet Susan in the movie
theater
I forgot that that's how he came on to
the show I'm just like really excited
about it
I love Orson I love the man who plays
him I love hire mcLaughlin no he yeah
and he also
Zach was watching on the Flintstones on
yes he's the baby and he's the boss yeah
I actually just watch The Flintstones
Ben had never just must have just gotten
to Netflix or something did Zach was
watching it it's so and I was just
looking over his shoulder and it was
still so good isn't it weird that Ben
has never seen Flintstone yeah like he
grew up in the same time as us and like
was a kid at one point
you guys should he could be Fred
Flintstone he is you do it for Halloween
you should be
and you could be burning and then Rosie
O'Donnell I'm good well I have to be
well my man BAM oh my god yes I really
need to start thinking creatively about
Halloween because it's coming up soon
even though I have no plan she was our
party
a toast Halloween I've actually been
invited to host a party at the dream
hotel maybe I should just do it so we
could like go and like have some damn
Halloween look yeah on Hallows Eve
yeah and it's a party I went to last
year Burton Yale and it was so fun love
it and we can all dress up as a family
feels like by human looks like buy a
ticket or anything like we just get a
table and like we have to pay for it
wait why wouldn't we do casino called me
when I was so busy and asked me if I
want to do it I was like okay crazy show
min I'll be don't know well I have to
see if I'm getting invited again to
Heidi Klum's Halloween party I feel like
I'm not because I feel like I would have
gone invited already but I was invited
for like the last two years and me and
been like you've made a splash both you
splash both year's costume wise and like
the guest list is getting like sadder
and sadder every year I've gone so like
why wouldn't I be invited but I guess
I'm a disgrace now so like maybe nobody
wants to like me but if I didn't raise
you up to hang out with your family
but if I do like I need to come up with
a really good potential costume and I
can't and no one is helping me well
think well there's a hollow Steen's
group where like people are putting
their Halloween inspiration and I asked
I'm like nobody could help me oh my god
maybe I should be Taylor Swift and Joe
and then let them go alone because she's
never with Joe that would be funny but
that's like a thing yours what's
dressing up as Taylor Swift
mm I've always wanted the yellow bangs
uh create a showman for
remastered album coming out oh my god I
saw Kelly Clarkson Kelly Clarkson
singing ever enough Panic at the Disco
singing the greatest show like brown
bent Zac Brown man from now on pink
singing a million dreams her daughter
singing the reprise it's gonna be
unbelievable but I just love that
Hollywood it's not letting this stop
like the greatest showman has been on
the charts literally the movie came out
over a year ago
it's been on the charts every day since
it came out and it's like you could have
just like the movies over like you could
have let it die no it's coming to
Broadway they're remastering like I love
that we're never gonna let this end it's
like a star is born it's gonna be remade
for the next 100 years I'm so here for
it and PASOK and Paul were like when we
were selling a hundred thousand albums a
week we were like how do we make the
most of this if we were to come out with
like a Mother's Day version of the album
like what would it look like what would
people want yeah and like
so many celebrities are fans of the of
the movie and I'm so excited November so
excited
November 16th listening party oh by the
way we are doing by popular demand the
toasters demanded it and we work for the
toasters I always say I'm a caterer a
cater to what the toasters need we are
doing a toaster cell cycle class what
was the date I gave you November 12th
yeah the details will be posted it's a
charity ride for gift of life just so
it's good to get back to in the holiday
season it's right before Thanksgiving so
we could all hang I'm not sure if I will
it be on a bike or if I'll just be like
motivating other people because I just I
can't do it or maybe I'll teach if
that's what I just hope that we can pick
the playlist because I mean I've been
oppressed for the teacher they said the
way that it works it's like if he's
available he'll do it if not you get to
you still get to request I'm seeing him
tonight should I ask him like yeah but
available yes yes okay okay so it's
gonna be at night so everyone could come
after work there's 65 spikes I had to
google it like someone was asking me
like we were orbiting studios differ
like how many studios in it I'm like I
don't know oh I went on by the one that
we're doing we're doing Brian Park right
yeah that's big okay because I went to e
63rd and just like looked up a random
class to get the bikes and it went up to
64 that sounds about right
okay that's something a lot why are we
doing part because they you get to pick
three and that was one of the one I
picked because it's central like yeah
it's East it's West it's up its down I
feel like toasters come from all over so
I didn't want to like do like 83rd
Street and then people who live downtown
okay right so and it's like near where I
live now so I've watched you in there
so tickets will give you everything in
the next couple weeks but get excited I
am your toasters okay toasters okay I
picked up so as you guys know I feel
like we're getting so many new toasters
like every week that um I have to keep
like reminding people what do your
toasters it's great
dear toasters is every problem to have I
know is our advice segment where you can
submit anonymously to dare toasters at
gmail.com we really like the quirky
wines we used to do a lot of just like
relationship my boyfriend but like
that's kind of boring
and at the end of the day we always give
the same advice so I want like quirky
weird stuff so we've gotten a lot of
weird submissions so keep sending them
we'll always keep your name and Amin
anonymous dear toasters at gmail.com
this one round two
too small or too weird this one is
titled am i being harassed by my
weatherman yes I work doing marketing
for an air conditioning company that I
used to love however now it's hell there
are many reasons why but the main is a
weatherman basically one day a washed-up
weatherman called our company and said
he needed a new air conditioner our air
conditioners average cost is twelve
thousand dollars
he is somewhat of a local celebrity and
asked if we could exchange advertising
endorsements for an a/c basically he'll
do our ads in exchange for a new system
oh that's cool like he'll be on the
commercials Wow the local [ __ ] okay that
sounds like a good barter
yeah that does when this idea was
proposed I immediately was against it
this guy was so creepy and I don't want
to keep rambling but he was
inappropriate armed cell he's like he
would give us sponsorship
just pay the get an air conditioner like
probably for his house if he's the
number one weather man I can't you make
decent money
totally but $12,000 is a ton I've never
said $12,000 on anything I don't you
have $12,000 your a/c company is steep
totally maybe okay whatever maybe it's
like luxury right so he was
inappropriate touched my arm when no one
is looking showed me his shower when I
was at his house for initial appointment
and I told my bosses that I didn't want
to work with him they agreed and said I
think he's harmless and we're going to
do the endorsement but you will never
have to work with him alone however what
happens I've had to work with him alone
on several occasions this guy will call
my office five times in a row only to
ask me to lunch he'll stop by my office
unannounced give me a kiss on the cheek
he messages me on Instagram and the list
goes on it's [ __ ] awful and I hate it
I need to wrap this up but something
else you should know is that we don't
have an HR department what angers me the
most is that I feel like as if the
workplace environment is protecting me
I've already voiced my concerns and said
I don't want to work with him why do I
have to be the one who has to go again
and say that I'm uncomfortable it will
lead to the company losing $12,000 and I
feel like it's humiliating what do I do
definitely don't feel elated like by the
way it's not like you work in a brothel
like you work in an air conditioning
company for you to feel uncomfortable
with a man it's like so alright and that
they should be taking it seriously your
job to like make you feel like that's
the price if to pay to get the job done
like no that's not the price you have to
pay for it an air conditioner right like
you don't have to be in by the way
twelve thousand dollars like is a lot
for someone to pay but it's not a lot
for a company to lose we're like the
little the least amount of money they
can spend a customer can spend in your
in your office is twelve thousand
dollars like losing one customer like
isn't should it be late you don't to
lose a customer you say I understand
that you want it I'm a letting you know
officially that I am not working on it
like no but you already said that
he's not respecting that like how can
you I know what they said they owe
messaging you on Instagram like they the
company needs to take a stand and you
say it's either you or him and by the
way she's him then you go to your local
law firm right but by the way violence
to do everything via email with things
like this you have to leave a record
right so like being chats of the DNA
shots of the DM screenshots of the email
you wrote email him now like don't do
anything in person or if you do [ __ ]
record that [ __ ] on your phone every
time when I was an intern I had a
conversation with someone that I felt
like I was in trouble I would record it
on my phone that's always like gives me
such a pit like meet you like can they
see it yeah this is gonna make like a
sound recording finished like oh my god
I would die what is that um document
everything take it to your higher-ups
and you know if they fail you again like
you have a case on your hands you got a
call better call Saul and also like if
they continue to fail you you can give
us your local weather Entenmann's name
and we will publish named him we just
need all the evidence and we're happy to
do it I always I never know like what
the line is with tear toasters which
brings me to my next one because the
girl who sent it sent a picture like um
accompanying it but I didn't was
obviously not gonna put it because it's
like the picture it's not if the girl
who wrote in it's about like another
girl you know what does it give context
to the story may be petty may save a
life picture included so here I'll read
it to you and then I'll tell you nothing
major but basically there's a girl on a
fit on Facebook who I know a friend of a
friend whose eyebrows are out of control
it bothered me so much that I'd roll how
oh I need to see the picture yes but I
wasn't gonna put it on the stream but
out of control unibrow out of control
like thin girl Sonia drawn in unibrow
big bushy like doesn't pencil them in
even though they're blonde and they're
red hair and people expect them to have
black eyebrows like a dragon I would
consider those out of control those are
like Kelsey levy status ya know they're
they're really but they work for Eugene
Levy okay so it bothered me so much that
I unfollowed her and then I would still
see her somehow pop up up my newsfeed
with her eyebrows legit just smiling at
me iein friended her and then later out
a friend request from her I'm so nervous
that she's gonna ask me why I unfriend
her and I can't say because your
eyebrows frighten me can i this is so
for our problems and may seem harsh but
I really just want to know why her
eyebrows are so big and bushy and not
cute bar not cute like Cara bushy like
[ __ ] there is a forest above your eyes
or should I use a girl code and be like
hey you should propagate those suckers
whacks the odds of me ever seeing her
again are slim to none so I just don't
so do I just move on with my life or
help us this to out a picture included
so you don't think I'm overreacting the
girls like so pretty and like her boobs
are amazing she couldn't be skinnier oh
here's another picture Oh God
oh wow it's too here because this girl's
like gorgeous would not say anything
this girl has chosen to have her
eyebrows when you say this like friend
of a friend like you don't know her
she's proud also they look groomed like
it's not like she doesn't groom her
eyebrows and she obviously it feels like
her eyebrows to find her there are
people who are like not Cara Delevingne
who have chosen till I grow their
eyebrows out who have like really thick
eyebrows and that's their thing she took
it like once innit I just have to say
thank you far I'm really glad that she
said it's yours no her meet you I think
guys I'd be like why I'm just automatic
but these are the biggest eyebrows I've
ever seen Oh totally I say that they're
they're tall and short it's so weird and
oh my god and they're I would say
they're better than you jeez they're
like a big squirt a it's an inch how big
would you say like haven't I told us oh
I don't know I think it's an inch wow
that's a big eyebrow no but she likes
how she looks right now cuz this girl
she's obviously a girl who cares about
you I want to be Facebook friends of her
this is it fascinating she's so pretty
this girl like I would say she could
even be a model if she took care of her
eyebrows happy yeah fascinating
transition she but she obviously grooms
herself she cares about she look she's
wearing makeup her hair highlights she
looks leave her alone totally and I want
to be faced with friends with her so I
can see her confidence shine through
this is so funny don't say anything you
don't even know her you did it she looks
she's a gorgeous girl like she colors
her hair she takes care of her body she
wears makeup like she didn't forget
about her eyebrows right and you also
said like you don't really know her
she's a friend of a friend and the odds
have you ever seeing her again are slim
to none so decline her friend request
if you don't ever see her again you're
never gonna have to explain why you
declined it and then she asked you to
speak like I'm cutting down on my
Facebook friends like I don't really use
Facebook but that's what I do like I
used to have over 2,000 Facebook friends
and I'm like zeroing in on 500 and I
just keep her moving people non-stop and
like even people I'm like I like if I
saw I would say hi but like I don't need
to be up with their lives and especially
with all the toast groups like I feel
like I've lost control of my facebook
and I'm trying to get in control just
personal anecdote so I'm taking eyebrow
girl side on this like toaster I love
you thank you for the support
like I'm on the tester side this is so
funny no but like this girl likes how
she looks like leave her alone
you totally know her no but she that's
why she's not gonna say devil you don't
sign anything but you can she asked if
she should say something don't but you
can have your own personal opinions
about it for sure you can write into the
toes hi ladies this is our third and
final tear toaster tear toasters if you
ever want to submit for next week your
toasters at gmail.com my coworker and I
are in a predicament and need your
assistance
first it would probably help to have an
understanding of how our office is set
up we have an open floor plan where
there are six people to a table three on
one side three on the other my coworker
sits directly across from me and she
sits right next to the co-worker in
question let's call him lin-manuel
lin-manuel claims that he has eaten a
ham sandwich for lunch every single day
for the past six years straight every
day promptly at 12 p.m. he goes over the
mini-fridge takes out his ham sandwich
back to and brings it back to his desk
he claims that he has yeah he unwraps it
but then like he's saying like he's
never not eating a ham sandwich for
lunch and she's right like you literally
every day at noon he unwraps his
sandwich and it immediately smells like
something has died in our office my
Judas ham sandwich is just a slice of
ham slot between two slices of bread no
condiments no cheese etc as if things
aren't bad enough he then pulls out the
same flavor of Chobani yogurt and a
mildly bruised banana to eat alongside
the hand sandwich he eats the three in
this order one bite of ham one spoonful
of yogurt and then a bite of banana oh
man you know over and over until all are
finished we don't think he swallows
between each bite and he chews with his
mouth open we are at our wits end with
lin-manuel and need to get your guys's
advice on whether would you go about
telling him to stop eating the same
smelly lunch every day
or just leave it alone thanks ladies
love you both
this is so disgusting and I know exactly
what you mean like when there are people
there was a girl on my bunk who so
disgustingly that literally like I
couldn't eat breakfast like it made me
so nauseous like there are people who
are just disgusting eaters and eat
discussing things and they make you not
want to eat and it's like okay if he's
eating at every day at 12:00 like you
know it's time for you to go out for
lunch eat lunch you don't need to sit at
the desk
you get 30 minutes here's the thing you
can't do anything about him being a
gross eater like that's just unfortunate
but if his food does smell like that
sounds like a problem for HR really yeah
and I think that's like break it if it's
really like stinking up the joint like
if someone had a body odor or char at
work like you could tell HR that and
they because the hosts
it becomes hrs problem but I would never
want to work in HR like HR is basically
having uncomfortable conversations all
day no but there are people who are just
like made for it and like who want to
interview people and that's like the
flip side of the job that's not good but
it make like all the other people in
human interactions who are made for HR
like member when we were at o'the up
long girl Emily she was cute sweet like
she was perfect yeah for HR like there
are just people who were born to work in
HR and I'm not one of them who are just
like people person good like good judges
of character like good interview people
and they have good intuition and they're
they make awkward situations like easy
yeah I am the opposite of someone who
should work in HR same I need to work in
finance and like not talk to anyone but
I'm not that smart
yeah soon Harvard Business School how
was that coming I mean I have my GMAT
buff I'm gonna take a practice test like
in a few days whenever I'm feeling like
mints I have a lot of work to do so and
I've been like I've just been neglecting
all my email so maybe next week I'll
take my team a test see where we're at
good luck isn't it exciting yeah it's
just something like a new thing to think
about yeah no I was talking about about
that executive program that I found at
Harvard and then I realized that you
have to pay for Business School and
that's when I decided I wasn't going
anymore
understood I'm definitely not getting a
scholarship no you like have to take out
student loans or something and I only
think that like Harvard or Wharton it is
like worth that for me for sure but at
the same time it's like like I wouldn't
take out like loans to go to like NYU or
Columbia like I don't I don't want it
that I don't know right because like
we're really do it like if we were to do
this it would be like as a novelty and
like it wouldn't really like we wouldn't
we're not in the type of business we're
having it would further our career that
much like it would just be like kind of
funny and like corny and exactly so I'm
not spending whatever business school
I've really literally when Ben said it
he was like oh you're gonna have to pay
for it I'm like oh my god I totally
forgot about that part it's two years
right and it's like what 50 I don't know
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it like
if I'm gonna spend [ __ ] 50 grand on
something that's gonna advance my career
and getting a Birkin knock if I'm yeah I
need okay let's say it's a hundred grand
to go to business school if I'm spending
a hundred grand on something that's
gonna advance my career you know what
it's gonna be um
I mean for me and be like plastic
surgery liposuction no funny I would
literally go into the pocket of like
Judd Apatow and I would just really put
me in a movie yeah yeah it'd be paying
off like everyone you
not [ __ ] is I'm sitting in some
boring as a lecture interesting just a
thoughts you think yeah cool what else
we have nothing wow I feel like toast
movie of the week with Secretariat let's
talk about its Marcos I haven't seen
watching Rick brush up so if you will
give you time if you haven't watched I
never carry it toes moving the week
beautiful movie about voice you can
watch it with your kids it's a family
friendly so Riverdale's on tonight I'm
gonna watch keeping up and then we're
also seeing a star is born so let's talk
about all that tomorrow oh my god I'm so
excited I really like need to see a
stars warn you it's really crazy how
it's just taken over like the dialogue
yeah I know everyone's fighting about it
she should like hopefully it will be
oscar-nominated yeah and she can
potentially be an e dot I watched his
video that was like their fret like
their friendship is goals you know and
it's like all the nice things I said
about each other grab the N word yeah
and it was so cute it was like she's
like you're supposed to work with people
who are better than you and like Bradley
is so much better than me like he's so
good and then he was like when I first
heard her saying like I could like and
then he was like and she didn't stop
singing for a year cuz like literally
the whole movie is singing he was like
it never gets the whole movies thing I
didn't realize how many good songs we
were gonna get we got a whole new Lady
Gaga album yeah which is I'm loving it
but a toaster be nice to touch good
advice because I was about to listen to
the thing on Spotify and had 34 songs
and I was like oh my god there's Cylon
yeah there's dialogue in the album on
Spotify which contains spoilers because
like it just gives you like I said I
don't even know what movies about
without a woman I didn't know what it
was about either I know it's something
about the song that's all I know so
don't listen to the one that's bad
there's one without the dialogue right
or just see the movie no no no it's like
I forgot yes I forget okay I'm so
excited to talk about the movie and to
see it again because I need a second of
course I need to watch it again the
second watching of a movie is almost
better than the first sometimes no the
first what especially when you don't
know much about a movie like not knowing
where it's going is like so exciting I'm
it was like slow at times and I was like
I don't mind because I'm just like watch
I like will you both remind me cuz
you're gonna be at my house before to
bring my glasses like I need to bring my
glasses to the movies like I don't want
to admit it but like I need glasses but
I used Benz just for TV and movies so
make sure I bring it cuz like I'll be
really annoyed if I don't okay someone
DMA it like now and see how she bring
his glasses - I was said to mark on the
way here should I bring Theo to the
movies
we'll be after nine o'clock he'll be a
sleepy silly he'll be sleepy but like if
there's popcorn on the floor like he'll
go me insane
yeah and it works animal he can do
whatever the [ __ ] he want to be like I'm
not gonna eat today just so I can like
be really fat at the movies I'm going to
SoulCycle and then I'm gonna be even
better oh great it makes more room thank
you guys so much for watching the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you like us on
Facebook and subscribe to us on YouTube
that way you never miss an episode
subscribe to us on YouTube because
eventually we are no longer assuming on
Facebook we had this discussion last
night and we just have to do it November
1st
nobody is something else happening on
November 1st something really good so oh
yeah okay start saving your money now
after Thanksgiving no more Facebook okay
that's what we're giving up for
Thanksgiving we're no longer thankful
for face because also [ __ ] like
there's 33,000 people in the toasters
group and we have 20,000 likes on
Facebook like the 13,000 I need that
haven't like to some Facebook like you
can literally grab a spoon know and also
and then there's 24 thousand YouTube
subscribers so the nine thousand if you
haven't subscribed to us on YouTube
grab a spoon as well and then subscribe
to us on youtube right YouTube is
premium as hell you guys it's so much
better I love the super trick I have a
whole channel yeah it's so great watch
everything we can clip it and also it
generates ad revenue for us to keep this
show alive so right if you look does
nothing if you care about us you'll
watch us on YouTube so that we can keep
renting this very expensive studio right
after Thanksgiving no more Facebook and
counting down the days that's excited
that's a good idea
yeah so we've big things happening
November 1st that will tell you about a
little bit sooner we have that soul
cycle ride coming up so just make sure
you're following us on Instagram because
we'll post all the updates and then
starting after Thanksgiving we're
officially done with Facebook and
YouTube know we're officially done with
faces just Facebook I was going back
into like my end alright so make sure to
subscribe to us on YouTube like this
video leave a comment whatever you want
we know we need to film a new travel
trailers we do that today oh yeah we're
looking cute and then also if you're a
podcaster you can't watch live and make
sure to subscribe to us on Apple iTunes
and unspotted I we're also available
pretty much anywhere podcast can we
listen to stitcher public radio and Cass
box like a random apps just like there's
no excuse for you not to be in tune with
that's sorry so make sure you're in tune
and have an amazing day and follow me on
instagram i takeo problems
you